I have a lot of Little House in the Prairie fans that follow me
because of my connection with Little House,
and so that is why I'm making this video.
But I really need this video to gain traction
so people can be aware of what's going on in the Little House world,
because this is extremely important.
And so if you watch Little House on the Prairie
or you know somebody that watches Little House on the Prairie,
please send this to them or comment below,
because this is a very important message that needs to be talked about
of what's going. What's going on right now,
because it's absolutely crazy.
I'm gonna introduce myself very quickly.
My name is Jennifer Brawler.
I am Dean Butler, who played Almanza Wilder.
Almanza Wilder on Little House on the prairies.
Social media director. And I work very closely with him
along with some of the other cast members
from Little House on the Prairie.
Especially in the last month
and the most recent events of what's happened.
I am in the daily grind of Little House.
Little House is my full time job.
So it all began about a month ago, uh,
when the Little House on the Prairie cast had separated themselves
from a promoter who was doing Little House on the Prairie events
all around the country. They were traveling from city to city.
They were doing events for the 50th anniversary year.
That's this year. And they have Been extremely busy.
About a month ago, they did an event in Connecticut,
in Pennsylvania, that was extremely poorly organized.
Oversold tickets. People were waiting for six to seven hours,
sometimes longer, to meet people.
There was lack of food, there was a lack of ADA policies.
There was a lot of issues that happened in this,
and people were very hurt by it.
People lost a lot of money.
People paid a lot of money,
didn't even get to meet the cast
because of this organizer and the promoter
and the lack of organization that took place
and that carried on in Pennsylvania.
It was like a back to back event.
So after all of that, the cast of Little House on the Prairie
removed themselves from this promoter
and cancelled the events for the rest of the year.
They had four other events scheduled.
One in Miles, Tennessee,
one in, uh, Keystone,
South Dakota, one in Branson,
Missouri, and one in Corsicana,
Texas. And the cast canceled those and said,
we will not ever be working with this promoter ever again
because of the way that they handled these events.
And this is where it gets pretty crazy.
When they made the statement,
when they said, hey, guys,
we're done. We're cancelling these events,
they thought the promoter would go to eventbrite
and cancel the events for the rest of the year.
But this promoter did not do that.
No, no, no.
They put sold out on all of The things
so they did not have to start issue refunds right away.
So these people, these fans
thought that these events were still happening
when they were already cancelled.
People were showing up to these events
expecting to see the cast of Little House on the Prairie,
and there was nobody there.
People were absolutely devastated.
People lost so much money.
They haven't received refunds.
They're dis disputing their credit cards.
It has been a massive mess.
It was not until Melissa Gilbert,
who played Laura Inglis Wilder,
went public with this and it hit national news.
People magazine came out with an article about this,
all of this. And that is when the promoter finally changed the events
from sold out to cancelled.
Now, while I am so glad that that is all happened,
there are so many people that have been so hurt by this situation
and by this promoter, and it is absolutely devastating.
I'm talking about so many people
that are still owed thousands of dollars,
vendors that have not been paid.
It's absolutely atrocious what has happened.
Now, I say all that to say today,
Dean Butler, Alison Argrem,
and Pamela Bob
came out with an episode called the elephant in the room
on the Little House 50 podcast.
I, I really encourage you to go listen to it
so you can hear more
behind the scenes of what actually happened to the cast.
Also, the fans have been affected deeply.
The cast was Affected deeply.
So many people have been hurt by this promoter,
and I wanted to make a video for my followers
so that they could be aware.
To bring awareness of what's been going on
and how devastating all of this is.
I grew up watching Little House.
I'm a massive fan of Little House,
and now being able to work with such incredible people
is a dream come true of mine.
And it breaks my heart
that so many fans have been affected by this terrible situation.
I want you to know that the cast is grieving just as much as you are.
They. They have been hurt deeply by the situation.
And there are things going on behind the scenes,
and I really hope this man is brought to justice.